enfin vous montrer un corps enlevés en
utilisant un trombone basse est bien
d'accord et est-ce qu'on a du beurre du
burn out ça pour du beurre et un trône
et les forces sociales utilise c'était
ok très bien sûr toi je préfère d'accord
voyez monsieur marocaine
alors attention je ne sens pas le rosbif
vole compté jusqu'à dix sont dotés de
disques à 0 attention 10 ont commencé
you say party
[Applaudissements]
attendu secondes
seconde il va enlever les menottes
attention à nos pensées on va passer
pour des cons en allemand mais j'y crois
pas du tout et coûteront mode on n'a pas
les clefs sait pas on les a pas de qui
quand je suis arrivée la police
et elles sont ils pensent qu'elles sont
dans sa loge
est ce que tu veux qu'on aille en somme
chercher les clés dans la loge où
l'anomie ok vous en faites pas ce que
j'appelle la police de polices et que ça
sert cette connerie on pouvait trouver
cela je commence à être pas bien voilà
il me voyant l oms est pas bien frais je
suis ravi de ma mère j'ai la rage et la
rattrape pas me sortir la tablette avec
toi toi c'est toi c'est toi toi je te
kiffe
non mais on n'est pas bien là
alors comment tu vas faire là bas je
sais pas fair au matin à 1069 étape à la
conac mais oui mais pour lui demanda lui
d'où tu croyais avec lazy bones ou en
maille
[Applaudissements]
attention là c'est qui celui-là
serrurier pour nos fans mais sans
équivoque et les chevriers témoin les a
mis là la mare où les garçons musclés
mais il est trop vous êtes allée des
gaffes aller 0 0
parce que là tu en train de faire un cas
tu vas fermer ses défauts merci tu veux
[Applaudissements]
je suis pas l'homme mais pas mal bouffe
c'est trop je vais avec trois
magnifiques voilà cette année admet
sortez moi de là ils ont raison les gars
de france inter venait me chercher faire
que ça rigolait les gars y'a une vache
qui passe on est tranquille et le gaz
tranquille elle fait sa vie quoi
[Applaudissements]
ces métiers en france
et
chambre
beaucoup de choses à mener tout cas
faire comme ça
[Rires]
à
c'est là c'est la seule émission on
accueille quant à l'invité normale en
direct gens dire allez tout de suite
laquelle j'ai passé le k way effet dû
s'habiller tout c'est notre nation est
arrivé
[Applaudissements]
c'est la station genre il a l'habitude
des plateaux lorsqu'on vient de jeter
ses amis gays jogar du plateau les
chemins de fer joggeurs pujadas sur le
jt de bouger les doigts serrés bouge pas
parce qu avant de couper la main wise as
rome mais oui c'était des témoins ben
justement si je rate mon coup c'est fini
bah oui dans ce bar the bien moi je
cours vite maintenant mais pas de faire
des nouvelles coupes la main ça coupe le
3 mai les facteurs attention mesdames
parce qu'elle est très serré un bar est
de toucher à ce connaisseur et non ça
marche par hacker bien la connerie c'est
la torah dont loi attend je ne dis pas
que c'est la clé soirée merci c'est la
curée non tu sais la queue et cyril
virez les tous regardent
aucun mot garde aucun si c'est la clé
non mais à mon avis c'est l'autre qui
vous la donner avec la ils
affaibliraient non fois alors sur des
collectes mois il a fait exprès on la
coupe la clé tiens tiens ça résume au
fait qu'est venu pour rien enfin non je
suis pas venu pour rien hu beauvau
[Applaudissements]
lalonde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]